Oh,
hello!
My audio thing reset itself!
Damn!
So unlucky!
What happened to my overlay?
Oh my god!
Why is the chat overlay white?!
I'm so fucking unlucky.
Give me a sec, I gotta figure this out.
What's going on?!
Why is my CSS not working?!
Why is it not working?!
I am not...
Like, it hates me...
Oh my god, I don't even know what the overlay is!
What happened?!
Is...
Oh, everyone's CSS... Oh my god!
Why is life like this?
Why?!
Okay.
Is it for everybody or is it just me?
I just... That's all I need to know.
Please, tell me.
Is it for everybody or is it just me right now?
Do any other VTubers have this issue?
It's just me?!
Oh, everybody.
Oh, thank god.
As long as everybody else suffers, that's fine with me.
I'm okay.
As long as everybody else is suffering and having a bad day, then I'm happy.
Oh my god.
Alireza had it yesterday!
Why did it hit me today?!
Like, why did I decide to be like...
No, we shouldn't hit her, we shouldn't give her the bad codes, like the broken CSS yesterday.
We should do it... we should do it, like, today.
That's when she's having the most issues right now.
Oh my god, I'm so...
Alright, so...
Oh my god, the amount of money I've spent today and yesterday...
I'm so mad, because I had...
Okay, okay, I'll start from the beginning.
I'm so sorry, I hate being late.
Like, really, really late for streams.
Because it's like, so out of my control.
And it's like, I'm sorry, because I'm wasting your time.
Because you guys are all here waiting for me.
And I'm sorry, everybody.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my god, I'm going through a lot right now.
I just... it's just really frustrating, because it's like, out of my control.
And I'm just like, why does it always hit me?
Alright, this was my breaking point.
Okay, we're gonna play this game soon.
But after this game, I'm gonna take...
I might have to play God of War.
For like, maybe an hour or so.
Because I'm gonna take the PC to the shop.
Alright, last... okay, I'm gonna start from the very beginning.
Alright, story time with Doki.
I'm gonna start from... also let me... is Sound Guy here today?
I don't know if Sound Guy is here today.
Because like, I don't know.
I'm worried that I'm starting... I'm gonna start like...
My mic's gonna start crackling too at the moment.
Because I'm going... I'm going through a lot of stuff.
Alright, Sound Guy, let me know if I start crackling or whatever.
Alright.
We'll start from the beginning.
Tell you how this all went.
So, you all know how... how like, you know...
We were... we were talking about getting new RAM, right?
And I was like, yeah, I'm gonna just take it to the shop.
Yeah, because like, you know, I'm afraid.
I'm gonna fuck it up.
Like, you know.
And then, you know, Tenjin...
You guys were like, it's just RAM.
How could you fuck it up?
You just swap the RAM and click it in place.
And I was like, oh, I don't know.
There's always... I've always had issues with PC problems.
And like... and like, I don't know.
That's like... that's why I don't... I don't...
You should just take it to the PC.
Because like, you know, I always have issues.
And then Tenjin was like, you can pay me and I'll insert the RAM.
Don't take it to the store.
Just swap the RAM.
It's that easy.
It's just RAM.
Little did I know.
This just RAM issue...
Turned out to be a lot more!
Than just fucking RAM!
Okay, anyway.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't you know that we all slept together makes my 101F feel work.
Make it less difficult as well.
Thank you.
So!
I have...
I have a lot of work to do.
So, um... and I played a little Overwatch, but like that's not what that matters right now.
So, so at like, um, at like 11pm or midnight, I... okay, so I did a lot of work.
I went to the store.
Sorry, I got a little ahead of myself.
So I did some work first before I went to the PC store.
Um, I went to the PC store and, uh, and you know, I was like, hey, I need RAM.
I need like, I looked up the RAM I have.
I was like, I need 32 gigabytes, uh, a stick, 16 gigabytes of stick.
And then so they're like, yeah, we have that, but it comes in black or is that okay?
I was like, I didn't really care, you know, I didn't care about like what color the RAM sticks are.
Like I don't look at it.
The PC's on the fucking floor.
My desk isn't long enough or big enough to fit.
A PC on the side because I have three monitors.
So I was like, that's all right.
It's not like I'm gonna look at it or anything.
Yet everything else in the PC is like, no, there's RGB.
It's at the end.
Like it's RGB, but the stick itself is not, it's not like fully white.
It's just black.
Um, so there's RGB at the, you know, at the corner thing.
And so like, so like, I was like, I don't care because I was like, oh yeah, that's fine.
It's not like I look at my PC anyway, because it's literally on the floor.
Like not on the floor.
It has a little balcony thing.
So it's not sitting on the fucking carpet.
It has like a little like, like balcony ledge thing, my desk that purchased it.
So like, it's not touching the floor.
So like, um, so I was like, by the way, it's touching the floor right now.
So like, whatever, like at this point, like if it fucking, I don't care anymore.
Like...
I don't care anymore.
I...
I'm not at this point...
We're in Tokyo.
I went through so much.
I...
HAHAHAHAHAHAHAHA HAHAHAHAHAHAHA Anyway...
So I was like, it's alright if it's just all white except for like the two RAM sticks that's black.
I'm fine with that.
Like I don't care.
So they're like, alright.
And then click click click click click click click click.
I don't want to type on my keyboard right now.
But they're like click click click click click click click.
And they're like, oh but we have these RAM sticks.
They're not the same brand.
But...
It is an upgrade.
And it's only $20 more.
So yeah I'm thinking...
Oh upgrade.
HAHAHAHAHAHA HAHAHAHAHA And only $20 more?
I was just like...
But it's the same thing right?
And he's like, yeah it's basically the same specs.
It's the same specs.
And like...
And it's just like...
I don't remember what...
There was something minor that was like...
More of an upgrade.
I don't fucking remember the details.
I just heard upgrade and it's only $20 more.
So I was like, alright that's cool.
Yeah.
I was like, are you sure it works on my build?
Because I have like a profile with them.
Because they're the same place I take to fix my PC and stuff.
And they were like, yeah.
And they were looking up and they were like, yeah yeah.
You took this PC for the AMD stuff right?
And I was like, yeah.
And they were like, yeah yeah.
It works with your build.
It will even be like an improvement to your build.
So I was like, oh sweet.
Cool.
Alright.
Yeah.
Fuck it.
Let's go.
I'll buy it.
Like, if you say so.
And it's white too.
It's fully white.
So it'll fit the build.
Because like, it's gonna be all white.
No, it's DDR5.
It's literally the same.
Like, I checked it.
I was like, are you sure?
It's like DDR5 and like 6000's whatever the fuck that was.
And they were like, yeah.
It's literally the same except for like some fucking upgrade thing.
And I don't know.
I don't remember what the upgrade was.
So.
I was just like, alright cool.
I was like, are you sure it's gonna work with my build?
And he's like, yeah.
It will.
Because he looked at my profile!
He looked at my fucking PC specs profile!
Because they were the same store I went to bring to fix my computer.
When it came to like AMD.
This AMD CPU motherboard.
So they know what my motherboard is.
They...
They sold you magic beans a million.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Anyway.
So.
I like...
I brought the RAM back.
By the way, I couldn't...
Like the store closed by then when I figured out...
I couldn't like go back and exchange it.
And...
And then so.
I...
You know.
I went home.
Did other work stuff.
Because I knew like if I do the RAM stuff it's gonna be like a whole different whole thing.
So I was...
Not home.
Sorry.
The old apartment.
Where my PC still is.
And then so.
So like I did other stuff.
Before like I came back to you know.
Um.
At 11pm or midnight.
I went to install my RAM.
Alright.
So.
I haven't done...
Sorry.
I like...
I paused because I'm sad.
Sorry.
The sadness.
Like overwhelmed me.
So I had to pause a little bit.
Alright.
So.
I...
You know.
The worst part about doing all this.
Is that.
Um.
It's very inconvenient.
Plugging and unplugging all the cables again.
Um.
Because I can't see the...
The ports for the display.
For the monitors.
So I have to like always feel for it.
Um.
Because it's like really up against the wall.
The desk.
So like I had to plug and unplug.
So many fucking times.
It was so... That was like one of the most frustrating parts.
So like at this point.
That's why I'm like.
I'm not even putting it into the god damn cubby hole anymore.
I'm putting it on the fucking floor.
Because I cannot be bothered.
Because I'm gonna be unplugging it again.
Anyway.
When I take it to the shop.
Okay.
So.
Um.
This is what happened.
First attempt.
Plugged in the RAM sticks.
And then.
My monitor wouldn't turn on.
And I was like.
Why isn't it turning on?
I was like.
But.
The first attempt.
The colors weren't on.
So I.
So like.
I was like.
Wait.
Did I not plug it in correctly?
Because the colors weren't on.
Because like.
It's been like years since I plugged in RAM.
Because I had an attempt trying to swap in RAM.
And I think.
I also failed spectacularly.
So that's why I like.
Don't.
I remember now why I take.
I don't even trust myself with RAM.
Because this is not the first time I fucked it up.
This was in university.
Um.
Anyway.
So I was like.
Wait.
The colors aren't on.
The RGB's not on.
So.
I tried it on and off.
And then I was like.
Maybe I need to push it in harder.
And so like.
I pushed it in harder until I heard the click.
On both ends.
I heard the click on one of the ends.
Um.
Oh wait.
No.
That's the first.
The first attempt had no clicks.
So I heard a click on one end.
One of the ends.
And then.
So I turned it on.
I was like.
The colors on.
Yippee.
Alright.
So I was like.
I'm gonna try it on.
It worked.
I did it.
I was so happy.
I was like.
Yeah.
I did it.
It was that easy.
Oh my god.
They were right.
Plugging in RAM was that easy.
Little did I know.
Nothing turned on.
The monitor didn't turn on.
And I was like.
Wait.
That's not how it's supposed to happen.
Why is the colors.
I was like.
Oh maybe it's cause I need two sticks.
Maybe that's why.
Like.
Maybe I just need both of the sticks in.
So then I plugged in the second stick.
I plugged in the second stick.
Until I heard one click.
And then.
I was like.
Oh.
The monitor didn't turn on.
I was like.
Oh.
Why didn't the monitor turn on?
I was very frustrated.
I was.
By the way.
I just need you to know.
There's two openings on my PC.
I was very fucking frustrated.
Because I didn't want.
The first time.
I didn't want to like.
Bring my PC out fully out of the cubby hole.
Because it's very frustrating and tilting.
To put it in the cubby hole.
So I was just like.
Okay.
I'm just gonna like.
Halfway push it out of the cubby hole.
And then work on one end.
Of the.
One end of the glass.
Because there's like two sides.
One is where like.
You know.
You can access everything.
The other is the side panel.
So like.
Not the back side.
But like the tiny square rectangular side.
The really tiny rectangular side.
I used that to plug in the RAM.
Because I was like.
By the way.
I had to have the flashlight on too.
Like on my phone.
So I was just like.
Alright.
Because I thought.
I thought.
It was gonna be so easy.
Hahahaha.
Anyway.
I think like.
One hour passed.
During all of this.
Never plug in RAM.
When the power is on.
Hahahaha.
I may or may not have done that.
Like once or twice.
Because I was so mad and frustrated.
I just need to know that.
I was incredibly frustrated.
And have done that at least once or twice.
Today or yesterday.
Yesterday.
Once.
Twice yesterday.
And once today.
Hahahaha.
Um.
Anyway.
Hahahaha.
That's what I was saying.
Um.
Okay.
But like.
I did turn the PC on.
It was just the power was plugged in.
That's all I'll say.
I didn't turn the PC on.
When I swapped it.
But like.
When I took it out.
The plug was plugged in.
Hahahaha.
I forgot to unplug it.
Not forgot.
I was so frustrated.
Oh that's fine.
Okay.
I did not do that.
I did not unplug.
I did not take the RAM out while the PC is on.
By the way.
I did not do that.
I just did that like.
Three times.
Um.
Yesterday and today.
While the outlet was on.
And then I was like.
Oh fuck.
Okay.
Whatever.
Hahahaha.
No.
I didn't do that.
Okay.
Anyway.
So that's one hour.
And I was very sad.
And frustrated.
Cause I was like.
That was one hour's past.
By the way.
And so.
So.
I was very desperate.
I like texted one of my.
Tech literate friends.
Who works in IT.
And stuff.
And I was like.
Uh.
Hahahaha.
I was like.
I don't know what to do.
Hahahaha.
I like took a picture of the RAM.
I was like.
What am I doing wrong?
Hahahaha.
And.
They were like.
Um.
Okay.
Did you fully plugged in the RAM?
And I was like.
I think so.
The colors are on.
There's.
There's colors on it.
It's RGB.
And then my friend was like.
Yes.
But did you fully pushed it in?
The colors can turn on.
Even if it's half way in.
I was like.
I can't do that.
But like.
The colors are on.
Hahahaha.
So I realized.
I only pushed it half way in.
So.
Hahahaha.
I didn't hear two clicks.
I heard one click.
Because apparently only the one half of it.
Um.
One half of it.
Was in.
The other half wasn't.
Um.
So.
I pushed it all the way in.
For two clicks this time.
And I turned it on.
But.
The monitor didn't turn on.
I was so confused.
Why is my monitor not turning on?
So.
Then we went through all of that.
And I was like.
Are you sure you put it two.
I swear to god.
If anybody says.
Are you sure you put it two four.
Are you sure.
I swear to god.
If I see.
Hahahaha.
I am.
I was like.
I literally just put it.
Where my old RAM was.
Yes it's at two to four.
Hahahaha.
I know I'm stupid.
But yes.
It was at two four.
Hahahaha.
Okay.
So.
Um.
So basically.
I was so confused.
I was like.
Why is it not.
Why is the monitor not turning on.
Like what's going on.
So then.
They were like.
Oh maybe.
Maybe you should try one stick at a time.
I was like.
Oh okay.
I'll.
Put them one and two.
Thank you.
So by the way.
They also were.
We got desperate.
At one point we put three four.
And it was so hard to take out one of the RAM sticks.
Because like.
We couldn't figure out.
We were fucking troubleshooting for four hours.
I need to know.
We were fucking troubleshooting for four fucking hours.
Um.
I went home at four in the morning.
Hahahaha.
Because I thought I was the problem.
Okay.
As I was saying.
Um.
So.
At that point.
I took out the entire PC.
Out of the cubby hole.
And like.
Opened the side panel.
The full front panel.
Because at that point I was like.
By the way.
It's like night time.
I can barely see anything.
So even with the flashlight.
It's so hard to see anything.
By the way.
They were like.
Are you sure you put in the right side?
So they want me to turn around it?
And I turned it around.
And I couldn't click it in.
So I knew it was the right side.
Because I couldn't turn it around.
And put it on.
Anyway.
Hahahaha.
So.
This is the moment where I fucking finally.
Pulled out the entire fucking PC.
Out of the cubby.
And.
Decided to use the front panel.
I can't.
I can't deal with this anymore.
And so.
I swapped RAM sticks around.
And put the 4 in the 2.
And the 2 in the 4.
Nothing worked.
And so I did one stick.
One stick at 4.
And so.
It turned on.
And I was like.
Oh my god.
It's on.
And it didn't take me to like.
My loading screen.
It was stuck in this weird ass screen.
Where it was like.
It is incompatible or something.
I don't know.
It just gave me some weird fucking.
Like.
Tech info.
Where they're like.
We detect like zero hard drive.
One mouse.
One keyboard.
Two SSDs.
Like it gave me that.
So I was so confused.
I was like.
What does that mean?
I don't understand.
Why can't I get to anywhere?
And then they're like.
Go to the BIOS.
And I was like.
Okay.
Save and quit.
So it'll go straight to the loading screen.
So then.
Save and quit.
And then it went back to that fucking.
Random ass.
Menu thing.
And I was so confused.
I was like.
What does that mean?
Why can't I.
But it's on.
The PC is on.
The miner is on.
So then I was like.
Okay.
I am going to.
I am going to now try the other RAM stick.
Maybe the other RAM stick.
And then.
It's the same thing.
It works.
It takes me to that screen.
And I was like.
Now I am going to put two RAM sticks in.
And the moment.
I put in.
Two RAM sticks.
My monitor doesn't turn on.
So I was confused.
I was like.
One works but two doesn't?
What?
What do you mean?
I don't understand.
So.
So I was like.
What did I do wrong?
Everybody said.
It was so easy.
That it's just RAM.
I was like.
What did I do wrong?
I
was like.
What did I do wrong?
I was like.
So.
Okay.
I am going to.
I give up.
After the four hour.
I gave up.
Because I was so tired.
I was so fucking tired.
I was like.
I put in my old RAM.
It works.
Oh.
My old RAM works.
Wow.
So.
At the four hour mark.
I was like.
I give up.
I'm just.
I'm just going to buy.
I was like.
Maybe it's this RAM.
Maybe it's incompatible.
For my PC.
Even though the seller said it was compatible.
Maybe it wasn't compatible.
And.
After they looked at my fucking profile.
Okay.
I was like.
I'm just going to go back and buy the black RAM.
Because it's the same brand.
I'm just going to buy the black RAM.
Since it's the same.
Same one.
And like.
It's just 64 instead of 32.
And then.
And then my friend was like.
Just take your PC to the shop.
I was like.
No.
Why did I say no.
Like.
It's not compatible.
I don't need to take it to the shop.
My dragoons and tangents said it's that easy.
Maybe I just.
Maybe the RAM is just.
Incompatible.
And I'll just get new RAM.
And it'll be fine.
I know how to swap RAM now.
Like I learned.
And my friend was like.
You should really take the PC to the shop.
You should really let them handle it.
You should.
I think they can handle this.
I really think you should take it.
I was like.
But it's so heavy.
I was just like.
But the PC is so heavy.
Though.
It's just easier.
To go.
I don't want to carry my PC.
Early in the morning.
I'm tired.
I don't want to be able to sleep much.
Because we've been doing this.
I was like.
I don't want to go.
So early in the morning.
I have two streams today.
So I chose.
To just exchange the RAM.
To the one I actually wanted.
And so.
So.
The worst part of all of this.
Is that.
Instead of taking public transport.
That was so much cheaper.
I had to Uber.
At 4 in the morning.
And that shit was expensive.
All the money I saved yesterday.
By taking public transport.
By googling how to pay for bus.
Gone.
Because I had to Uber.
At 4 in the morning.
It's so sad.
Because the next.
The next fucking bus.
Was at 5 in the morning.
And I was like.
I'm not going to wait an hour.
To fucking.
I want to be in bed.
Like at that point.
I was like.
I want to be in bed.
I don't want to fucking wait an hour.
For the.
Just drive.
I've not touched a car in 9 years.
If I just drive.
At 4 in the morning.
When it's night time.
I barely am surviving during the day.
Let alone night.
Like.
But.
Anyway.
I have a driver's license.
I just don't.
I just haven't driven.
Since getting it.
Anyway.
Look the roads have to be safe.
For people.
And putting me behind a car.
Is not going to make that happen.
Anyway.
Fast forward to.
Today.
Fast forward to today.
So I was like.
Oh.
I'm going to go to the PC store.
Um.
I'm so tired.
I was like.
I need to get there.
Before my stream.
But like.
It's okay.
The public transport to the PC place.
Can't be that bad.
One hour.
Laughing.
And it was already like.
Like.
11.
11 something ish.
Because I had to go to a specific place.
Because I had to go back to the same store.
To return it.
And I was just like.
And I was nothing.
Look.
I had to be back by 12.30.
I was not going to risk it.
Anyway.
Stream did get delayed.
I didn't think it was going to be.
I thought it was going to be on time.
Because I thought.
Oh.
If I had the right RAM.
Everything will be fine.
Anyway.
Guess who had to Uber again.
Guess.
Laughing.
So.
I had to pay for another Uber.
Laughing.
To get to the fucking PC store.
Because I was like.
I don't think I'm going to make it there in time.
If I take public transport.
Public transport.
It's going to take me an hour.
I'm not going to make it in time.
And.
I had to take public transport.
Back to the old apartment.
Because I was like.
I'm not taking a second.
I'm holding RAM.
Second Uber.
Laughing.
And so.
I went to the store.
And I was like.
Hi.
I got this RAM.
That your staff recommended.
But it wouldn't work.
One stick worked.
But when I plugged in two sticks.
It didn't work.
And I think it's incompatible.
Or like.
Doesn't match with my motherboard.
And CPU.
And they were like.
They were like.
Alright.
Let's test it out.
Are you sure?
Are you sure it's incompatible?
I don't know.
I don't know anymore.
Laughing.
I was like.
I don't know anymore.
Laughing.
So.
So they were like.
Alright.
We're gonna plug.
We're gonna test it out for you.
Just to make sure.
So they like.
And they like came back.
And was like.
Yeah it was faulty.
Sorry.
And I was like.
Laughing.
They were like.
Yeah sorry.
The RAM sticks were defective.
Laughing.
And the RAM sticks were defective.
They were fucking.
I was so.
Ahhhh.
Laughing.
I bought those sticks.
For a recommendation.
Because a man said.
Oh it's just $20 more.
It'll be an upgrade.
And I was like.
An upgrade?
And it was defective.
It was looking defective.
Laughing.
I paid.
Uber.
I paid for Uber.
Last day.
Because of some RAM.
Laughing.
Oh my god.
Anyway.
I was like.
They were like.
Do you want the same one?
You know.
The same one.
Or do you want like.
That old.
The other brand.
Like the same brand that you had before.
I was like.
I would like those black sticks please.
Laughing.
Because I wasn't going to risk it again.
I wasn't going to fucking risk it again.
Laughing.
It looks just like the old sticks.
But black.
And like.
32 gigabytes more.
And I'm just like.
Okay.
That should be fine.
Like.
It's just RAM.
Just like everybody else said.
Laughing.
I took public transport.
Back to my old place.
And then I was like.
Alright.
I'm going to.
Take the fucking PC.
Oh wait.
No.
The PC is not out of the cubby hole.
I stopped putting it in the cubby hole after that.
And then I plugged in.
I plugged in.
Both of the new RAM in.
And then I turned it on.
And I saw the monitor turned on.
And my lock screen.
Is on as well.
And I was like.
Oh my god.
It's working.
And I pushed it all into the cubby hole.
And after that.
I was like.
Alright.
It's working.
That's all I need to know.
I turned off my PC.
Plugged everything back into my fucking.
Cubby hole.
Plugged all my wires in.
And everything.
Turn the PC back on.
And I was like.
Oh my god.
Everything is working.
And I looked at my task manager.
Memory.
64.
I was like.
Oh my god.
It's working.
It's 64.
Turn on Chrome.
Blue screen of death.
Something is wrong with your PC.
And I was like.
Huh?
What?
I made it this far.
What do you mean blue screen of death?
And then the monitor would not turn back on.
We're going to restart your PC for you.
And to figure out what the issue is.
And the monitor never turned back on.
The monitor never turned back on.
I had to.
I pushed it out of the cubby hole.
And I was like.
Okay.
What's the issue now?
Swap the RAM sticks.
Swap the 4 to the 2.
To the 2 and the 4.
And then.
So it didn't work.
Nothing worked.
You were here.
You were all here.
Nothing worked.
Everything just led me back to the blue screen.
Laughing.
Everything led me back to the blue screen.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I worked with PC assembly lines in the past.
Defective RAM slots or RAM sticks are an occasional occurrence.
It feels like 1 to 60 sticks are likely to be defective.
You won the lottery!
Thank you for the super chat, Rage.
Thank you, thank you.
How many lotteries am I gonna win related to PCs?
How many?
How many times?
I've won the Intel lottery twice.
Back to back.
I won the RAM lottery.
I won the tw...
Everybody else is okay with their PCs.
Yeah, I absorbed everyone else's PC problems.
Every single PC problem that occurs in the world.
I absorb it all.
It doesn't matter how much money I throw into the problem.
It doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter if I'm an unlucky bitch.
Like...
Oh my god.
It doesn't matter.
I can't believe it.
Every inch.
The thing is, this has been a consistent issue in my life ever since I started streaming.
It doesn't matter how much money I throw at the problem.
I'll always have something go wrong.
I'm making more money now.
But it's still the same.
It's still the fucking same.
It's actually crazy.
It doesn't just affect my PCs.
It affects my laptops too.
Like, I don't understand.
I...
Oh my god...
Santino, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Here's a bid to wish you the next Uber.
Guess who has to take an Uber to bring this PC to the fucking store.
That's right!
That's another Uber today.
I'm so sad.
I have to take a back to back Uber too by the way.
Because I have to take an Uber to the store and then an Uber back from the store.
I'm gonna fucking... I'm gonna be like...
Please, I don't care if there's 20 PCs ahead of me.
It's RAB and literally everybody says it's just RAB.
So clearly you know how to do it fast.
I swear to God, if you make me wait two fucking hours.
Or the next day to pick up my PC when everybody has told me it's just RAB.
I swear to fucking God.
Because apparently it's so easy.
Oh my God.
So yeah.
Anyway, after all that shit.
After I plugged it.
By the way, for those who got here late.
It did not end with me plugging back my old RAM.
Because the moment I fucking...
I plugged in my old RAM so nothing was...
40 minutes delay, stream delay.
But like no progress at all for my PC.
It's like...
40 minutes delay, stream delay.
40 minutes.
Like stream got delayed for 40 minutes.
No progress happened.
No upgrades has happened.
My PC is still the same.
So I was like, alright, fuck it.
I'm gonna stream.
It's Disney.
It's a Disney fucking game.
Like how much intensive is that gonna be?
It's not gonna be Apex intensive.
I'm not gonna get some fucking frame drops or studies from a goddamn Animal Crossing rip off.
Like...
So...
Oh my god.
This is...
So... anyway.
Anyway.
Yeah, I boot up YouTube.
I boot up YouTube.
And I boot up...
Yeah, I was like, why couldn't I load YouTube?
Because I'm an indie, I can say it.
I use... I do use adblocker.
And apparently...
Today of all days...
They figured it out.
They figured...
I think they fucking took it down.
Because the adblocker extension got like...
fucked up for some reason.
And...
And they're like, it's...
It is not compatible anymore.
But I didn't realize.
Because I...
They're like, you gotta disable it.
And I was like, alright, I'll disable it.
Like, I disabled it.
And it wouldn't work.
And apparently...
Like, why today of all days?
For like, the government to send fucking people to their offices.
And unplug their servers.
Why today?
I don't...
I'm already going through a lot.
Why did it have to be today?
So...
I found out...
I found out that...
I had to delete my cache.
I had to delete...
For like, today.
Just today though.
Because whatever happened to that particular adblock...
It like...
Caused something funky with Chrome.
So I had to delete the cache for today.
And then boot it back up.
And I could load stuff again.
And then I was like, okay.
Maybe that was it.
Because I was like...
I don't fucking want to get ads.
Like...
I thought that...
Oh, maybe it's just a one time thing.
I just turned it back on after fixing it.
And deleted the cache.
But then the problem came back.
The problem came back.
And I was like...
The adblock doesn't really work today.
So...
It's off now.
I was like...
Maybe it's a one time thing.
I was going through so much today.
Okay.
I thought maybe...
That one thing would be nice to me.
Would be kinder to me.
But apparently not.
Marina, thank you for the aca-soupa.
Thank you.
Have you tried turning it on and off again?
Thank you for the aca-soupa.
Thank you.
That was my day.
My last two days.
That was my last two days.
It was so fucking...
Oh my god.
I've been through a lot.
I've been through so much.
Alright.
Last two days of...
Pure suffering.
By the way.
So I forgot to tell you guys a story.
Um...
This other story.
I'll tell this other story while we're at it.
It's been an hour.
We haven't even played the game yet.
But...
But while I was moving.
I fucked up with booking the elevator for the move.
So I had to call for the move in.
So I had to call the receptionist.
The concierge.
And I was like...
Um...
I'm sort of like late.
My overbooking is gonna end in like 10 minutes.
I know.
I'm so sorry.
There was a delay.
There was no delay.
We were just very inefficient over time.
I was like...
There was a delay with the movers coming in.
And like...
But I'm here.
And I was just wondering...
What do I do?
What do I do in this scenario?
Because like...
And they're like...
Sorry ma'am.
Only one person can move in at this time slot.
Because we don't have a lot of room for the second truck.
You know the rules.
And I was like...
Oh but like...
I can't go back.
I paid for the movers.
You're not family.
I paid lots of money for the movers.
I don't know what to do.
I can't just send them back.
Where do I put my...
And then they're like...
They're like...
Ma 'am I'm sorry but like...
Uh...
They're like...
We're sorry but like...
You know we can't...
We can't really do anything because...
We have other people trying to move in too.
Not just you.
No!
Where do I put my...
I can't just you know...
I can't just...
Turn the car away.
So...
They're like...
How about you go use the parking lot.
Okay?
And you can use any of the elevators.
We know you have...
I'm like... Oh thank you.
I'm sorry again.
I couldn't turn the movers away.
Because like... I don't...
I can't have access to my old place anymore.
Like literally as I'm streaming at my old place.
I...
But it worked!
I just told a little white lie.
But it worked.
And I was able to move in some of my stuff.
But yeah.
It's just a little white lie.
Just a little bit.
Speak to 100.
Oh my god.
Anyway.
My day has been quite...
But guys.
I went to Korean BBQ by myself.
Yesterday.
Because I was going through so much.
And...
The thing is.
Korean BBQ is not a one person thing.
And so...
Because I...
I didn't eat...
Yesterday I didn't eat lunch guys.
I didn't eat lunch.
And I was so sad after everything I've been through.
So this was like...
This was like before...
Actually no.
This was sort of like a...
Semi victory thing.
Because I was like... I got the RAM!
Yeah!
So I was like...
You know.
Little did I know.
A lot of things were not going to go my way.
But I was like... Yesterday I was like... I got the RAM.
And everything.
I was like... I was just about to...
Ready to plug that RAM in.
Because it's just RAM.
It's just RAM.
So I was like...
Alright.
I am going...
To...
Go to this Korean BBQ place.
And celebrate!
And I don't care if I'm eating by myself.
Like... I'm going to treat myself!
Because I spent so much money on that fucking Korean BBQ.
The saddest part.
The fucking saddest part.
Was that...
All their combos...
And individual orders...
They were like...
Sorry.
I was like...
Oh for two people, for four people, for six people.
And then like...
The individual orders.
They were like...
Sorry.
You have to order at least like...
Two plates.
To justify sitting in this spot.
For the Korean BBQ spot.
So they were like...
I was like... Yeah that's fine.
But each individual plate comes with one bowl of rice.
So I was just like...
Well I'll just order a combo.
I'll just order the combo.
Because I was like... Well it's more expensive if I order two individual plates.
Because it comes with two rice.
Why don't I order combo number two?
So then... For two people.
So then I was like...
Is it possible to half the order?
Because like I'm one person.
And they were like... No.
They were like... No!
You cannot do that.
It has to... Like we can't make...
Adjustments and modifications.
So I was like...
Okay.
I'll order the combo for two please.
But can you pack up the one bowl of rice?
Because I thought it would be...
It would be less sad.
You know?
Like...
I was like...
I thought it would be less sad.
You know?
If like they just box up the second bowl of rice.
So like...
It wouldn't make me feel like...
I'm like...
Alone eating a combo for two.
So...
Because I haven't had Korean BBQ in so long.
And I was like...
I need my new RAM!
My 64GB RAM!
And I'm going to celebrate!
Little didn't I know.
That was not a celebration dinner.
That was just...
That was just the one happy thing before...
Misery comes in.
Obviously it was a lot.
It was a lot of fucking...
BBQ!
I was trying to like describe it.
There was a lot of stuff on the table.
I would show a picture but it would dox me.
It would dox like where I am.
So I was like...
It was so much.
And like...
I ate like... I don't know... 20%?
Because it was like 2% combo.
There was so much meat.
And then...
I had like...
A
giant ass steak!
Like what the fuck!
And then...
I was like...
This is a combo for two?
Anyway...
And then there was like...
Jajangmyeon...
What was it?
The other one.
The other transparent noodles.
Um...
Um... Fuck!
I forgot what it was called.
The brown noodles.
There was that and then there was like...
There was so much!
And then there was like those appetizer things.
And then...
And then there was chop che.
Yeah there was chop che.
And then...
Sorry I like jajangmyeon and chop che.
I like both of this.
I always get them mixed up in my head.
And then there was like...
Those little appetizers!
And then there was like two other...
There was dumplings!
And there was so much in this combo.
I was like what the fuck is... What's going on?
And then...
There was so many.
There was like two other stuff there.
And then...
For two people.
For me.
And then...
So I was like... I was like... Okay.
Maybe I shouldn't have ordered...
A combo for two.
Maybe.
And then there was like...
70% of the food left.
And I was done.
I was done.
I was like...
Can you please go back to the kitchen?
Can you take these raw...
I called a server.
And I was like...
Could you...
Could you like... please...
Like cook these raw meat...
Into the kitchen?
And like pack it up for me?
Cause there was so much.
And I was tired.
I wanted to sleep.
And there was 70% of it left.
And they were like... No.
You have to cook it yourself.
Like...
I was like... I was so sad.
I was like...
Okay.
So I just spent like 30 minutes...
On my table.
Just cooking the remainder.
But...
The remainder...
Of meat.
And like putting it on my plate.
And it was just a mountain of meat.
On my plate.
Because I...
It was just a mountain of meat on my plate.
And I was just like...
And I was just autopilot.
Just cheering like...
And I like pressed it into the grill.
Just to make it faster.
Because I couldn't...
I couldn't do this anymore.
I was like...
I was so tired.
And then...
I asked in the box.
And they gave me a box.
And I just put all the meat in the box.
And then...
You know the worst part?
I forgot to bring the rice.
I was like...
I brought in a box full of meat with no rice.
I
was like...
The rice.
They really hit the buzz.
And I was just like...
The rice.
I was like...
Oh my god.
Oh my...
So I spent a lot of money eating Korean barbecue by myself.
It was not celebratory dinner.
It was the last good thing that was going to happen to me.
For the day.
So yeah.
That was my life.
I told you guys.
I told you.
I'm an unlucky person when it comes to tech, when it comes to PC stuff.
I am literally the most unlucky person when it comes to PC problems.
Everything that can go wrong when it comes to PC stuff will go wrong for me.
It never changes and I have to pay for the Uber today to go to the PC store.
And I have to pay for the Uber to come back.
What does Rice have to do with a PC?
It's the aftermath.
It's like the little twist, you know?
Like, yes, the PC stuff is the stab in the gut, but the Rice was the twist of the knife.
It didn't have to happen, but it also did.
Alright, let's play this game.
By the way, I don't know if you guys know this, but this game...
This game is...
This is the main portion of the stream.
So, let's...
Let's play Disney Dreamlike Valley.
Alright.
So, for those who don't know, Ursula's Trash...
I bought the Gold Edition because, like, I don't...
If I...
I shouldn't have already wasted so much money to...
I... I don't...
I'm going through so...
Why did I buy the Gold Edition?
It's not like I'll play it more than once.
Like, what the fuck is wrong with me?
Like...
The Gold Edition...
Guys, the Gold Edition is only $30 more.
Like, I can't help it.
It's only $30 more.
I never learned.
Apparently, I just never learned.
Like...
I just...
I just never learned.
Alright.
We'll do a very high...
We're not...
Alright, let's see.
I don't even know if Sound Guy's still alive after...
After this.
Alright.
We're gonna turn down...
We're gonna turn this down.
Streamer-friendly.
No, get the copyright stuff in.
I don't fucking care anymore.
Fucking... I don't need the ad revenue on this one.
Alright, let's see.
Alright.
Here we go.
Alright, so for those who don't know...
This is literally...
Animal Crossing, but Disney.
And...
Expensive... Well, no, it's the same price as Animal Crossing.
So, like, honestly, they're both, like...
Way too expensive than what it should be.
But, like...
Alright, who do I wanna be?
Import an avatar?
Guys, make me write...
No, I'm joking.
Alright.
Let's...
Can I customize?
Alright, edit.
You know what?
No, I'm gonna make you guys.
I'm not gonna make me.
I'm gonna make you guys.
Alright, what's the closest?
Umm...
I'll start with, like, a male avatar.
Alright.
Let's see...
That's... Yeah, that's about right.
What the fuck?
There's no shit there!
What is there?
The fucking...
What's the name of Sasuke's fucking brother?
Alright.
We'll get Disney eyes.
What's this?
Oh, colors!
Kinda... Oh my god!
Oh my god, you're gonna be...
Reptile... You're gonna be the...
Reptile man.
Secret society.
This guy... What do you mean?
He's definitely a dragoon.
Alright, the secret...
Alright, let's see... Wait, what's this?
What does this change?
Oh, eyeshadow?
Let's see...
You're gonna be lizardman.
Oh, wait, okay.
We're gonna be lizardman.
The secret society.
What's this?
The Luminati.
I knew it!
I fucking knew the Luminati was real!
Oh, these eyebrows?
Okay.
Alright.
I'm gonna make the most lizard possible.
I guess that's pretty lizard-y.
Okay, I think the black eyebrows really sell it.
But...
Alright.
Ooh, the sharp nose.
Yes!
The lizardman!
Ha!
Okay.
Oh, yes!
Yes, okay.
I like that.
Uh... What color is this?
Uh...
Green?
Where the fuck is the green from?
Whatever.
What's this?
Oh!
That's what the green's from!
Okay.
Okay, I realize what the green is from.
Alright.
Alright, then I guess like...
I want it to be darker green then.
There you go.
Mmm... Maybe...
Oh, wait.
Maybe...
What?
You're seeing lizardman.
Secret society!
Don't you know?
The country's run by... The world is run by...
The lizard people!
Did you know that?
I fucking knew it!
Alright, jaw.
Okay.
Uh... I need to like...
I need to get more lizard-y.
I guess like that?
Yeah.
There we go.
And then...
Birthmarks?
Freckles?
Or...
Do lizards have freckles?
Do!
Hahaha!
Do lizards...
This is a good question.
Sorry, I haven't seen a lot of lizards in a long time.
But do lizards have freckles?
Not really.
Some do.
Nah, that's not.
That's not.
You guys already run the world.
You don't need like more...
Alright.
What's this hair?
Uhhh...
Oh my god.
This is like some fucking...
That is a Disney God.
Hahaha!
Fucking...
Oh, bug!
Oh!
Okay.
Let's see.
I could just make you Jeff Bezos.
You know what?
You're Jeff Bezos.
Hahaha!
You're just Jeff Bezos at this point.
Yeah, alright.
Hahaha!
I've never done anything like that.
What do you mean?
Jeffrey Bezos.
Hahaha!
Become one with the Bezos.
Alright.
I mean, he's like some...
I mean, he has been working up since he's divorced his wife.
So, like, he is going through a midlife crisis at the moment.
So, I'll give him...
I'll give him, like...
You know what?
He's starting to get...
Yeah.
I don't know.
Should I be nice to...
I mean, Jeff Bezos, you're a fucking billionaire.
You don't need a muscular body.
Alright, face paint.
What the fuck?
What are these?
What are...
What is this?
Hahaha!
He's divorced?
Yes!
His wife took, like, half of everything!
Alright.
You could have gotten the easy route and make us look like Zucker...
Yeah, but there's no Zuckerberg hair.
It's easier to just make...
a lizard man.
But, like, nobody ever talks about Bezos, though.
Ooh.
Ho ho ho!
That's not Bezos!
That's fucking...
Hahaha!
That's Mezos!
Okay, let's see.
Alright.
I think that's great.
Alright, Bezos.
Welcome to my Disney World.
This white chat thing is pissing me off.
I'm gonna...
Hahaha!
I'm already going...
I mean...
If it doesn't fix itself, if the CS does not fix itself... Okay, it does not.
Alright!
I'm gonna do something crazy.
You're only gonna see two of you guys talk.
Hahaha!
Alright.
It should be long... Okay.
Jeffrey...
Bezos...
Bezo?
Okay.
Haha!
Jeff... Alright.
We call him Jeff here.
Jeff Bezos.
There we go.
I'm on the...
I'm getting sexier.
Alright.
Jeff Bezos.
I think that's how... I mean...
How... There's no way I could fuck up spelling his name.
There's no way.
Jeffy...
Jeffy... My...
My friend Jeffy...
Bezos...
Okay.
Now I need to spell check.
Now I'm fucking paranoid.
Alright.
Jeff Bezos.
Okay.
Good.
I was actually paranoid.
I guess she spelled it wrong.
It's like there's no way I could fuck that up.
I've already fucked up a lot of stuff.
So... Jeff Bezos.
Alright.
Welcome to Disneyland!
Welcome to...
Disney Crossing.
After she... After Doki...
was at her breaking point, she fucking finally moved out of the city.
It's time to create the Disney Warehouse.
Jeffery Bezos has a childhood?
You can have that in the lizard society?
Jeff was a child?
He didn't... He didn't come out of the womb as a fucking 40 year old man?
He wasn't born at age 40?
Holy shit.
Yeah.
The lizard people don't sleep.
What is this?
He spawned in when Amazon came out.
Oh hey Berlin!
Oh my voice acted.
I love that.
Less reading.
And then the voice acting is just...
Oh...
Of course I'm...
On my spectacles and chatter.
Of course I'm real.
Jeff Bezos.
I can never be too sure around here.
I'm afraid you'll have to excuse me.
I haven't met anyone in ages.
And welcome to Dreamlight Valley my friend.
Dreamlight Valley?
This place is...
Sort of creepy.
Lolly thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Can I get a couple days late happy birthday?
Of course!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Lolly.
Yeah!
Once upon a time you couldn't find another realm.
With as much magic and wonder in it.
Oh but I haven't introduced myself yet.
You're no doubt wondering who I am.
You're Merlin.
You're very old.
You're a very odd old man.
That's right.
Odd old man.
Why I'm...
I'm Merlin.
I'll have you know.
I'm a wizard.
A very very powerful wizard.
And that's... if you're so powerful.
Why are there foreigners everywhere?
I'm a soothsayer.
A prognosticator.
I have the power to see into the future.
And I'm also quite skilled at alchemy and...
...precedicular action.
Now that that's settled.
There's a small matter of who you are.
You don't know who I am?
I'm Jeff Bezos.
Jeff Bezos.
Jeff Bezos?
Well the only way to get to Dreamlike Valley...
...is to pass through dreams.
So you must also possess...
...great magic.
Otherwise...
...how could you be here?
Amazon money bro!
Oh yes.
Great magic.
Better watch out Merlin.
I'm pretty good at magic myself.
You're not the only...
...soothslayer.
Whatever that shit is.
I knew it.
The power of money.
As you say, could be magic too.
In fact...
...I'm quite certain that you're...
...the one we've been waiting for.
You're gonna save Dreamlike Valley.
Oh my god.
What's in it for me?
Why all the joys of Dreamlike Valley of course.
If we are to...
...restore the valley to what it was...
...a place of magic...
...of wonder, of friendship...
...we need to stop the forgetting once and for all.
We must!
I'm sorry.
I can't seem to remember what we were talking about.
Oh they're starting to forget!
Merlin's the forgetting?
You can't forget.
I haven't bought Disney yet.
Ah yes.
The forgetting.
I haven't bought Disney with my...
...the boys money!
And has been hotel money!
You have to forgive me.
Now you can see where it gets its name.
You forgot.
Alright.
Listen closely.
I'll tell you the tale before I forget again.
He has dementia?
I mean, he's really fucking old.
So I won't...
...
Thanks to our ruler's magic.
Until our ruler vanished...
Wait, who ruled the land?
Our memories faded.
The valley became a shadow of itself.
We tried to save our memories of the life that it be.
Oh my god there's so many thorns!
And as I can see into the future, I knew that someday, someone will come help to restore the valley.
No!
Scrooge!
He found out Bezos was gonna show up!
And he won't be the richest...
The richest citizen in this valley!
I wanna know about the missing ruler.
It was Sora.
Well now, all the wonder, magic, and friendship in this valley came from our...
Friendship?
You can be friends with other people!
What do you mean friendship came from our ruler?
Was he like the one mutual friend that united everybody?
Like, they watched over the village and kept us safe from dark magic.
You're literally a magician!
What's the point of having a magician?
But one day, they started to act different.
Though I can scarcely remember it now.
And then our ruler simply...
vanished.
It's been years, I think.
I lost all track of time because of the forgetting.
Your ruler just...
up and left?
Doesn't sound like a great ruler, not gonna lie.
A good ruler would take care of the village and its people.
Not just run away.
I mean look at my Amazon warehouse!
Oh.
Our ruler...
was...
He's still the richest...
Sorry.
He's the richest lizard here.
Alright.
I'm ready to help restore the valley.
There's an option that was like, tell me more about the forgetting.
And I'm like, bro, people are literally forgetting!
Like, what do I need to know more about it?
Well, there's only one way to be absolutely certain you're the one destined to save Dreamlike Valley from the forgetting.
It'll be a small test of your magic!
You see, ever since the forgetting, I've been puzzled about this house blocked by the night thorns.
Come along!
We'll investigate it together!
Alright.
Left click or E to interact with your surroundings.
I need a apparently... well, oh god, I need to turn down...
Whoa!
Oh, they screwed you, Mickey!
My god!
I got to re-meet the richest duck in the world!
Alright, let me turn down the music.
And then... I need to turn down the sense, cause the sense- sensitivity is insane.
And turn up the game a little bit.
Alright.
That should be good.
Let me know, sound guy, if everything's good.
Well, okay.
Everything's not good for me.
The sense is still fucking...
Whoa!
How is the sense still...
insane?
I don't understand!
Alright.
Try to enter the house.
I've consulted my notes and discovered that night thorns began infesting Dreamlike Valley soon after a ruler disappeared.
No one, not even I, can remove the blasted things.
Only someone who can harness the magic of Dreamlike Valley will be able to.
And I'm sure not someone is...
Is you, Jeff Bezos!
I can't.
It always hits me.
Now for a test of your magic, time to bring out the wallet.
I mean wand.
Peter, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Of course!
Why else would I be here?
Well then, don't let me get in your way.
Now focus your thoughts on the night thorns.
That sounds too easy.
Perhaps it is.
Or perhaps it's the hardest thing you've ever done.
Only one way to find out.
Feel the magic within yourself and say the magic word.
Um...
Bippity boppity boo!
The fairy godmother's magical phrase?
Wise choice.
Hahaha!
Yeah!
Jeff Bezos!
This brush you can use to hide is the power of dream life magic!
Well then, there's no time to lose.
Let's go inside and see what's become of this house.
Is this my house?
Are you my Tom Nook?
This is me when I get my paycheck.
Warehouse?
I have a new warehouse for Amazon.
Don't worry Dream Life Valley.
You will have your one day shipping here too.
Oh dear.
The night thorns have made their way inside the house too.
That's strange.
Suddenly, I can't remember why we came in here.
Must be the night thorns.
Precisely.
Being near so many of the clouds, the mine.
You must remove them before they consume more memories!
Focus your magic once again, Jeff Bezos!
You're a wizard, Bezos!
I'm just standing there.
The power of money!
Be gone!
I am a billionaire!
The money bee!
Alright, nice!
I got a photo!
Alright, let's turn down the music a little bit more!
Be gone!
Oh, I can have music playing too.
Guys, I can turn on and off the fire!
Truly!
Truly wonderful!
Oh, what's this?
Yeah!
I did it, Merlin!
The glowing orb you pulled from the Night Thorn!
It's a memory!
It's like a fog has lifted!
And I can recall something of great importance!
Mickey Mouse and I were at the Dream Castle!
Something important!
What was it?
I want to see the castle!
As you should!
The castle is magnificent!
Though I'm afraid it's seen better days!
If only I could remember what we left there!
Well, we must go solve this mystery!
Extraordinary!
But wait!
There's something else returning to me!
Oh my God!
You've got a friend in me!
Can you guys hear that?
Ba-da!
You've got a friend in me!
Ba-da-da!
I wanna buy the castle!
We must find them quickly!
They're filled with ancient and powerful magic!
The royal tools and the magic!
If I could find those, then maybe I could...
learn more powerful...
learn more powerful magic!
Perhaps, but remember...
magic is only as pure as the heart that wields it!
First we must obtain the pickaxe!
When the forgetting came, and our rulers left...
we found the pickaxe driven into a bladed stone in the plaza.
Come to think of it...
that was around the time the sky went dark...
and the night thorns overran the plaza.
It's all a bit of a muddle, I'm afraid.
No one's been able to lift the pickaxe from the stone...
but then no one was you, Jeff Bezos!
And after all...
it wouldn't be the first time someone pulled something from a stone...
and became a hero of legend.
Ah yes, the legend of Jeff Bezos.
Pull the pickaxe from the stone!
You must also find three other royal tools.
The shovel...
the watering can...
and the fishing rod.
You'll need them for what's to come.
Oh my god!
I'm gonna fish!
Of course...
You'll need a safe place in the valley to eat, sleep, and keep your energy up.
It's got so... it's so small.
But was it always so?
In fact...
I seem to remember that the ruler of Dreamlike Valley had a house like this once.
Perhaps you'll do as much good for the valley as our ruler did.
In fact, here's a little something to get you started.
If you ever feel like you need a boost of energy...
there's something in there that will fill you right up.
I need to eat food?
What the fuck is that?
Now then...
I'll be at the Dream Castle.
You'll find me there when you're ready.
Oh, so it's like the old mayor.
So like...
the old mayor ditched this place...
and then I replaced him.
Alright, so I have...
um...
That is my quest... and...
Wait...
What the fuck did I just do?
What... what did... what am I...
Hello, my name is Jeff Bezos.
Oh, I took a picture?
Alright.
Alright, open.
I wish my heart was as pure as yours was, Jeff.
Darkblade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What's this?
Oh my god, get a backpack!
No, I'm not gonna quiff this.
Like, I'm off to a school trip.
What's this?
Oh my god, that black t-shirt!
No, the white shirt is the Bezos color.
Alright, let's put a chair.
Uh...
Oh, hey!
Let's...
Let's give myself a chair at least.
And then we'll get...
Uh...
Let's like...
Let's like minimalistic-lize this.
Alright.
There we go.
I gotta make sure it fits the Jeff vibe.
Alright, simple...
Where's the wooden floor?
There we go.
That's what Jeff likes.
Nice.
Alright, nice.
Everything's looking good.
Put on the backpack.
It's time for school.
Hahaha.
Nice.
What's this?
I got mail?
I don't got no mail.
Oh!
What's this?
Claim.
Alright.
Expires a rift in time.
Oh shit!
Claim.
Claim anyway?
No.
Okay, gold edition.
Oh!
Oh my god, I got a capybara!
This is a...
This is a gold!
Nice.
Hey Jeff Bezos!
I love giving treats to my pals and you're a one-year-old.
I'm Jeff as friends with Mickey?!
Alright.
Nice.
That's what we like to see.
Oh my god!
Guys, I'm friends with Mickey!
Jeff as friends with Mickey!
Alright, nice.
You know what?
Guys, this is very odd.
This is really important.
I gotta put my capybara... wait, where's my...
Where the fuck is the capybara?
What the fuck?
Okay.
What the fuck is this dreamlight arm?
Oh, there he is!
Wait, he's just... he's just there!
You're just there!
Do you follow me?
What are you?
No, he's just there.
Okay.
He's just there.
Alright, this should be worthy... check.
What the fuck is this?
Oh, is this where you sell stuff?
Oh, this is where you sell stuff.
Oh, he does follow me!
Fine, Merlin, wait... oh, there he is.
Alright, little Jeff.
Jeff's heart is the purest of them all.
Pure greed, that is.
How dare you?
Merlin's the purest of them all.
You said that I'm special.
Thank you for the super chat, Delta.
Thank you, thank you.
Jeff Bezos, this is the dream castle.
It holds many secrets.
Er, answers.
Er, uh, oh, blast it all.
I can't seem to remember what's inside.
I bet that inside the castle, we'll find...
Riches!
Riches beyond measures!
You'd rather sound like a Mr. McDuck, I know.
Well, you can call me Mr. McGlizzard.
Well, I'm no doubt the castle contains many wonders.
Let's hope they include the secret to restoring Dreamlight Valley to its former glory.
Let's see.
Those n- Let's go inside!
Easier said than done, Jeff Bezos.
The night thorns that encase the dream castle aren't like any you've dealt with before.
Rather peculiar.
They're stronger!
And will take more of your magic to defeat.
Follow me.
There's so much more to show you.
Alright, don't worry.
Oh, I have to follow you?
Oh my god.
Don't worry!
My legs!
I work out!
Everything in Dreamlight Valley is well made of Dreamlight!
The sparkles you see over everything and everyone.
Even wizards such as myself.
But Dreamlight...
Became scarcer and scarcer as the forgetting fell over the valley.
Wonderful!
Ever since you arrived though, the magic has started to come back.
I told you the power of money works.
The Scrooge got competition.
I want to make it stronger!
Alright.
But it's not through the desire of power that the magic grows.
Mm-hmm.
Dreamlight magic grows stronger through acts of friendship, love, and care.
The fuck is that?
Care?
Simple acts like removing night thorns or forging a friendship with me.
Gaze into the well and discover the different tasks that will create more Dreamlight.
And payments of $9.99.
Is there Twitch Prime here?
But to fully embrace the potential of Dreamlight, you'll need to gather the royal tools that were lost during the forgetting.
Remember, for some wizard, magic requires magical implants.
You'll need those tools to save Dreamlight Valley.
Mickey's been the guardian of the village since the forgetting.
Perhaps he knows the whereabouts of the watering can and the shovel.
Let's see.
Fishing!
Ah, yes!
Goofy is very fond of fishing.
Be sure to know where you can find the lost fishing rod.
Where's Donald?
I don't care about Goofy or Mickey!
I want...
Look, there's my capybara.
There she goes.
Till I've ever heard from him since the stones blocked our path to the meadow to the south.
Well, you must find him so I'd start there.
Why do I keep taking pictures?
What?
Use Dreamlight to restore the valley.
Remove knife thorns from the castle entrance and other parts of the valley.
Okay.
Gaze into this.
Alright, how many Dreamlights do I have?
I don't have a lot.
So I have to...
I have to go see Mickey.
Mickey's over there.
Is there a way to pull up my map faster?
Alright, I...
I assume...
Can I remove this?
Be gone!
Oh, hey, money.
Nice.
As Chef Bezo says.
Money.
Alright.
See ya.
I'll get rid of as many...
Oh my god, I got carrots too?
Stop, stop.
I keep petting the capybara.
I keep...
Instead of fucking removing the thorns.
Oh, I guess this is like where you garden and stuff, right?
No, that's just thorns.
That's just more thorns.
Oh, I can collect Dreamlight!
Alright.
I finished my job.
I finished my job of removing thorns.
So now I...
Now I can collect my Dreamlight.
Alright, nice.
I have to remove 230...
Okay, from like 20 to 230?
Like, what kind of jump was that?
Like, what the fuck?
Oh, hey there's...
Oh, whoops.
Okay.
What's this?
Rawr.
Alright, let's see.
What do we have here?
What can...
Oh, hey.
Okay.
Let's see.
Let's see what is there.
Oh, that's quite dreamy.
Not gonna lie.
That is quite dreamy.
Let's...
Nice.
Alright.
Save only.
Yes.
Actually, gotta screenshot this.
I'll do one too.
There you go.
Alright.
Alright, I took my photo.
Nice.
Oh.
There's a squirrel?
What the fuck you want?
The fuck would I give you anything?
I mean, you want carrot seed?
You don't want carrot seed?
Why the fuck I gave you carrot seed?
You said no.
That's messed up.
I actually got more carrot seeds anyway.
That's right.
This is why I have my capybara.
At least my capybara appreciates me.
Alright.
Good day to you.
You gave me quite a start.
Don't you know never to sneak up to someone while he's contemplating his investments?
Oh, I'm Jeff Bezos.
And you're Scrooge McDuck.
You're my hero.
Aye, that I am.
You must keep up with the business news.
Though my business isn't in a story state these days.
Just look at my shop.
The whole village is not so bad.
Ah, an optimist.
Good for you.
We shall see.
Some see hopelessness.
Others see opportunity.
After the sky went dark, most of the villagers skedaddled.
Where do they go?
To the fucking wild?
Like, why would they leave?
And fewer and fewer clients came in until they stopped altogether.
But I cannot remember where they all went.
I know I stayed to take care of my shop.
And my money, of course.
I'm gonna buy you up, Mr. McDuck.
Then...
Hmm...
Oh, yes.
The night thorns blocked me in.
And I cannot remember much after that.
But like...
Like glittering off gold, I'm starting to remember how the village used to be.
And all its investment opportunities.
I'd like to get in on this.
So, one of the replies is...
Life's more about more...
Life's about more than money.
Clearly.
They don't know who's playing this game right now.
Jeff Bezos.
Hmm...
I could use some help.
That much is true.
Perhaps we come to an arrangement.
Let's hear it.
I've got a deal for you, Jeff Bezos.
If you help me make enough star coins to put my shop back in business...
I'll make sure it's stocked with everything needed to put the valley back together.
Oh my god!
I'm opening my first...
I'm working with Scrooge McDuck to open my first Amazon warehouse!
Oh my god!
We're bringing back Prozac!
Prime!
Goofy used to have a stall in the meadow to the south.
I'm sure he apparently...
He appreciates any help you can give him.
That lad doesn't have a mind for money.
You'll need to find a way to bring...
To break the rocks blocking the road to the meadow when you do.
Find Goofy and help him get back in business.
Then you can help me with my grand reopening.
Oh, and I see you have a map there.
Don't forget to use it when you find your way around the village.
Alright, nice.
I have...
I have now acquired...
The button to open my map.
I've acquired the M.
Alright, nice!
Me and Mr. McDuck are gonna work together to...
Is it this way?
Me and Mr. McDuck are gonna work together to open the Amazon warehouse.
It's gonna be great!
Mickey!
I'm gonna get you out of here.
But what if I want you to forget so I can take over your empire?
Jeff Be- What?
Oh, that's Goofy.
Jeff Bezos!
Oh boy!
Am I glad to see you!
Mickey Mouse!
I'm a big fan!
Well, I'm a big fan of Mickey Mouse!
I'm a big fan of yours!
In fact...
I saw you talking to Merlin and came in to get something for ya.
Oh boy!
But I can't seem to remember what.
It must be because of these nightborns.
I'll help you remember, Mickey.
Don't worry, Mickey.
Mr. Bezos will help you remember the important thing.
I'll help you remember the important thing.
Sorry, I went goofy again.
Gosh!
These nightborns are the worst!
I tried everything and nothing works!
Oh, gosh!
Alright, time to make sure Mickey remembers!
Oh, wait, what's this?
Oh, not that.
Wait, why am I resting?
Alright, check.
Ba-da-dum!
Ba-dum!
What the fuck is this?
Puts on a good fro- Oh, is this the Mickey language?
But I can tell he's utterly heartbroken.
Minnie was his other ham.
Now that she's- No!
Mickey!
Minnie!
That's Atlantean?
Wait, is that really?
I can't believe it!
Minnie left Mickey!
I don't know how long it will be.
She took him!
It's okay, Mickey.
I, Jeff Bezos, know what it's like to get the Force.
That bitch took half of everything.
I'm gonna steal your stuff in the- Do you have anything in your chest?
Don't worry, that was my stuff, Mickey.
I know you forgot, but I kept it there for storage.
Ba-ba-dum!
Ba-dum!
Ba-da-dum!
Oh, my inventory is full?
What's in my inventory?
Do you want to buy these twi- I need a- Okay!
What the fuck?
Alright, let's open this.
How the fuck was I supposed to know I have limited storage?
Oh, my God!
I have the Mickey backpack!
The black- The black mi- That's why it was in storage.
He's trying to do everything he can to forget about her.
Alright.
Nice.
We got a book.
Ba-ba-dum!
That's fucked up.
But why did she keep the Minnie backpack?
Mickey, that's messed up!
You have to move on!
She's gone!
Oh, there's Remi!
And there's Eve?
What the fuck is Eve doing here?
She's so out of place!
Oh, there's the golden shovel!
Wait, the golden shovel's here!
She's so out of place!
What's she doing here?
He's dating another rat!
Oh, no, he's just so out of place.
He's supporting local rap businesses!
This is his restaurant!
He's supporting local rap businesses, guys!
Wait, I wanna... okay, I need to open this.
What do I not need?
Glass?
Okay.
I'm trying to figure out what I don't need.
Alright, we don't need dandelions, guys.
We don't need medicine here.
Guys, we don't need medicine in... in Dreamlight Valley.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
Maybe that's why Minnie left him.
He's like, I forgot what... why she left me.
I forgot...
Okay, that does not fit.
How do I open the book?
Somebody's like, open the book!
Alright, now I'll pick this back up.
I'll pick up the flowers back.
Alright, let's see.
So at least I can open the book.
Is this characters?
Oh, is it the characters?
Oh, I can have them change clothes!
We don't need that here.
I don't know what you're talking about.
We do not need that here.
What?
What was the book?
I don't know what the book was!
There's a shop?
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Why is this... why is there... I already paid $50... $80 and you want more of my money?
Like... like... what?
Why would I need skins?
Why would I need...
Oh my god... I seriously... Oh my god, I fucking get Carl's house though!
Astrum, thank you for the magenta soupa!
Thank you, thank you!
Hi Toki, it's my birthday today.
Can I get a birthday greeting?
Also hope you enjoy God Award later.
It's one of my favorite games, of course!
Happy birthday to you, happy birthday to you, happy birthday dear Astrum, happy birthday to you!
Yeah!
Thank you again for the magenta soupa!
I... I can't believe... Oh my god, I can't... These look like...
They look like ghosts!
They literally look like dead pets!
I'm like, what the fuck?
They look like dead fucking pets!
Holy shit!
Like...
What was the book?
Is the book like... the friendship?
How can... how many friends can I make?
Oh, Ricket Ralph...
Oh, Merlin...
What's the book?
I don't understand!
Is the book...
Oh, is it my inventory?
I did not see it.
Oh, there it is!
Guys, I just found the book.
I'm gonna learn to read right now.
Wait, what?
I learned how to cook?
Is that what the book's for?
Did I just learn how to make food?
I... I guess I did.
Is that what happened?
I guess I learned how to cook.
What a dog!
It's all coming back to me now.
Dreamlike Valley used to be full of friends.
Like my pal, Remy.
My very, very good friend Remy.
He was always trying out new recipes!
And I was always HAPPY to taste him!
Haha!
Where is Manny?
And all this...
Well, we don't talk about her.
We try to talk about Minnie when I'm there.
Hahahaha!
I also remember...
Oh my god, he also lost Remy?!
Who's Remy?
Oh, Remy's a great chef.
Runs the best restaurant in town.
Oh gosh.
Or, he did until the night born started infesting Dream Life Valley.
I buried his recipes all over the valley to keep him safe.
Have you ever heard about a safety deposit box, Mickey?
Like, why would you?
Have you heard about, like, compiling it into a cookbook?
It, uh, well, it seemed like the best idea at the time.
Uh-huh.
Hey, I got an idea.
Remy's recipes could help you make meals to keep your energy up while you help save the valley.
There's one recipe we can get right now.
He was trying to forget him.
Yet he kept Minnie's backpack.
The memory you found should give us a clue as to where we could find the recipe.
Well, what do you know?
Alright.
I can access the collection menu of, oh!
Select an item to discover more info about it, alright.
Buh duh dum buh buh dum buh buh dum buh dum buh dum buh dum buh dum buh dum.
Oh!
Woah!
Alright, it's time to cook!
It's time...
...to cook?
Haha!
Oh!
Oh, recipes.
Okay, I need bell pepper.
I don't have any of that, Mickey.
Mickey, how am I supposed to cook, Mickey?
You're supposed to provide me the stuff.
Mickey, how am I supposed to cook?
Mickey, stop running away.
Mickey, man, what should I do?
Well, now that we know what we're looking for, we have to just figure out where it is.
The memory should help us.
Where the fuck's... Oh, the memory with the chef.
Why do I have to find Mickey's stuff?
Mickey's the one that wants to eat.
He's just dancing.
He's just fucking dancing.
Mickey, help!
Where's my house?
I need to put stuff away.
I can't believe I have to actually put stuff away.
Jeff Bezos, how do I not have enough items, Jeff?
Alright, home sweet home.
Alright, we gotta, like, put some stuff away.
I don't have... apparently, I don't have enough money.
My storage is full?!
What's... okay.
This is a mess right now.
My storage is full!
Just stuff it all inside!
Alright.
We need to go to... where is that area, anyway?
Is it here?
Chef Remy!
There's the shovel!
The magic shovel!
Goddamn.
Every time I see his face.
Alright, nice.
Okay, tab.
And now, dig holes and remove obstacles.
What do I need to remove?
Like this?
Like, how do I... am I not using it?
Like...
Oh!
Okay, wait.
I can't... I can't remove it!
Oh, there it is.
Oh, there it is!
Nice.
What did I get?
I got rocks.
Nice.
Do I need to dig stuff back in, though?
I got more books!
Oh, no.
This village is gonna be...
We're gonna have some potholes.
I can't be bothered.
We're gonna have... we're gonna have potholes here.
Alright, nice.
But I'm here!
This is not where I have to go?
I need to get cheese and everything!
Oh, I need to explore.
Marlin, look!
I... what?
Where is it leading me?
Back to my home?
Why is it leading me back to my home?
I have so many questions.
Alright.
Why did it lead me back to my house?
Oh, yeah, the book!
I keep forgetting to read!
I can make a fruit salad!
Oh my god, thank god.
Okay.
Alright, Mickey!
I can now make a fruit salad!
Oh, boy, we did it!
We found the shovel!
And the recipe!
More, more!
Fruit salad?
Oh, hehe.
All this shovel over fruit salad?
That's right, Jeff, you tell him.
Is it like some kind of magic fruit salad or something?
Well, all of Remy's recipes taste magical.
Even the simple ones.
Oh, this is stuff you don't know.
Is this why Minnie left, Mickey?
Is that why she left?
And I bet if you keep looking, you'll find some recipes that are a bit more exciting.
I know Remy will trust you with his recipes.
And I'm pretty sure you'll like making him.
Hmm, if I find more of Remy's recipes, maybe I could start my own restaurant and get rich!
Haha!
You sound like Donald's Uncle Scrooge!
Now, before you start collecting other recipes, we gotta make this one first!
First, we'll have to gather the ingredients, and I'll go see what I got in my garden!
Meet me there when you want to make the fruit salad!
It's been so long since I tasted one of Remy's recipes.
Has he ever said anything about Minnie this entire time?
It's been Remy this and Remy that.
He has not mentioned Minnie once in this entire scenario.
Oh,
and here's some overalls for you to wear if you want to look the part for what comes next!
Gardening!
Gardening?
That's what the maids do.
Select clothes to customize your... I don't need to customize my clothes.
I'm perfect the way I am.
Alright, I gardened.
Gosh, Chef Bezos!
There isn't much left of my garden!
Oh gosh!
It's a mess.
It sure is.
Minnie def- Oh!
Minnie mentioned!
Minnie definitely wouldn't be happy if she saw it like this.
She loves gardens.
Well, the sooner we make this recipe, the sooner we can make Dreamlight Valley a place she'll be proud of again.
Okay.
The recipe says to prepare the fruit salad.
We need fruit, like apples?
I bet you can find some around the village.
Oh, you know what would be great with a fruit salad?
Some crackers?
Who the fuck puts crack-
This is why you don't follow the recipes from a fucking rat.
You want to make crackers and fruit- Oh yeah, you want to make crackers and fruit salad?
That's so...
Not doll.
Not exactly like high-quiz-y.
Oh gosh.
Just because it's not fancy doesn't mean it's not good.
But to tell you the truth, the real reason I want to make crackers is because that's what Minnie used to make.
It's not the same as your pesos.
Remy is tiny.
But Minnie, she's like my size.
Guess I just wish she was here to make them now.
Mickey, are you okay?
Why the fuck?
Me?
Oh, I'm fine.
I miss Minnie.
But it sure helps that you're here now.
Okay.
Minnie's crackers are super easy to bake.
They only take some wheat.
Here's the recipe.
Okay, I thought it said meat.
Yikes.
I forgot.
We'll have to start gardening before we can start cooking.
To get some wheat, we'll have to plant it.
Here's some seeds we can use.
Yay!
Cabbage, carrot.
It would be great to replace all those ugly thorns with some nice plants.
Alright.
Dig a garden.
Plant a seed.
Crops grow.
Alright.
Be gone.
Just like my ex-fiancee.
You gotta let her go, Vic.
Oooh.
Gee, you don't make crackers.
What the fuck?
I mean, I guess if Minnie made them, I guess.
That's crazy.
I was like, what?
Alright.
Okay.
Boom.
And then plant seed.
There we go.
Boom.
Okay.
How many does he want again?
Is it all five?
Oh, so that's what it was for.
Alright.
This beautiful garden of wheat.
Okay.
There we go.
That should be five.
That should be six.
Sorry, I can't numbers.
Cappy bird, get away!
Alright.
Oh, I can hold the plant mul- Okay, that's too late now.
Apparently, I could have held to plant multiple, but that's too late.
Alright, did the thing.
Oh, sorry.
I can't talk now.
I need to find the magic watering can.
Where the fuck is the magic watering can?
Merlin!
Where's the magic watering can?
Oh, I should grab the- I should grab some apples.
Harvest my apple now.
Maybe near the water?
You would expect so.
But like, it's not.
Like, there's the magic well.
Alright.
Let's see here.
Where could the magic watering can be?
I can't just ask me to do your fucking thing without telling me where the magic watering can is.
This town isn't even that big!
Why are you bald?
Because we're Jeff fucking Bezos.
He'll never grow hair.
The more hair he... if he grows hair, he loses his fortune.
That's the price he pays... to be a billionaire.
Okay, we can't go through here.
There's literally nowhere to go.
Oh, there's the magic pickaxe!
Yay!
And thus...
The sky...
And then it's morning?
The magic pickaxe destroyed the moon!
Like, what?
With this magic pickaxe, the moon shall be no more!
What the fuck?
Like, destroy the moon!
And then...
Bezos said...
Let there be light!
My word!
You pulled the pickaxe from the stone!
I mined the moon!
Oh, and look!
Now that the enchanted pickaxe is in the hands of someone worthy again...
The blasted darkness that hung over the valley has finally disappeared!
Call me the hero of Dreamlight Valley.
Heheh.
No, I'm afraid one can't simply decide that they're a hero.
That's a title which must be bestowed upon you by your peers.
But I know you'll do many great deeds here and prove yourself worthy.
Mm-hmm.
Now that the pickaxe...
Now, the pickaxe is just one of the tools that we all aid you on your journey.
Not only will it help you find gems, but you can use it to break through rocks and stones to explore the valley!
I see now that it's your destiny to bring great change to our valley.
What kind of change?
I like the village how it is!
Actually, no, I don't.
I want more people here.
Well, that's entirely in your hands.
You've already started on your journey!
Why?
Because...
Because of you, I'm remembering how dreamlike valley once was!
And how it came to be in the future.
We lost so much, you know?
Not just memories and tools, but magic and friendship too.
Those of us who stayed when the forgetting began have been scattered.
Some are even trapped!
It's up to you to find them!
Alright, nice.
With my giant-ass pickaxe...
I shall save the world!
But where is the magic watering can?
I am literally missing the magic watering can, Merlin.
What the fuck?
How do I progress in this quest if I can't water?
Like... what do you want me to do?
I'm trying to water!
You know what?
Okay, I thought I could like...
I thought I could like... destroy that rock.
Oh my god!
I'm literally just...
You know what?
Fuck this.
I'm gonna...
Fuck this rock!
Oh my god, I got new crafting materials!
Maybe there's like... the magic watering can is somewhere here.
Down here.
Hello?
Is there any magic?
Any magic?
Oh hey, what's this?
What's this?
It's another memory.
I'm using Rivalry lately.
Scrooge camped for the life of him to figure out why Goofy's stall is more profitable.
Goofy started trying to help and that's going about as funnily as Goofy's help always does.
Oh my god, Goofy was like the secret...
Uh... wait, you saw the watering can?
Wait, is that it?
No, that's not it.
Where the fuck is the magic watering can?
Where's the magic...
Oh, there's the magic fishing rod.
And thus I can fish now!
I'm gonna start fishing.
Jeffrey Bezos.
Wait, I can't?
I can't just learn... I can't just fish?
Oh my god.
I have to find Goofy to fish?
That's stupid.
That's...
That's fucking stupid.
I'm Jeffrey Bezos!
Why are you trying to say that I'm stupid?
I can't... do fishing myself?
That I need a dog to teach me how to fish?
You need the power of magic to learn to fish.
That's fucking stupid.
Alright.
And thus...
I dig.
Boom.
I like how it just takes one hit.
Oh, I'm tired.
I'm not used to physical labor.
Sorry.
Usually...
Usually, somebody else does this for me.
Wait, is the...
Could the...
Maybe the magic...
Maybe the magic watering can is here!
Okay.
That's a chest.
Maybe it's here?
Maybe it's here.
Am I gonna pass out if I'm too tired?
No, it's just a rock.
What's this?
It's not a magic watering can.
Guys!
Where's the magic water...
You guys think I don't wanna progress this mission.
Where the fuck is the magic watering can?
Where's that one guy that's played this game?
I...
There has to be one of you that's played this game.
The plaza is the heart of Dreamlight Valley.
It's where all the Valley citizens come together to help each other when needed and celebrate whenever we have an excuse.
Oh my god, please.
Please, I just...
I have all the magical tools.
Except for the fucking magic watering can!
Maybe somebody said it could be behind my house.
There's a behind in my house?
No, that's a chest.
Oh, there it is!
I see it!
Why is it here?
What the fuck?
Who put the magic watering can here?
Yes, I did it!
The watering can has been unlocked!
Thank fucking god.
I like how it's the pickaxe that like...
That like brought the day back.
Everything else doesn't matter.
Alright.
The magic watering can.
Eat some food or go back to your house.
God damn it!
What if I like just pass out?
Oh no, I can't.
Sorry, I'm EP, Mickey.
I mean...
I'm kidding.
Sorry, Mickey.
I'm EP now.
That's all it takes?
That's literally...
Now sync to real time.
What?
Okay, your time will change.
The characters will follow their own schedule.
Make sure to come back...
Wait, that's pretty funny.
So they have like their own schedule and everything.
They have their own AI.
Oh, that's convenient.
Oh, now you are alive.
Alright, did the thing, Mickey.
What do I do now?
Do I wait?
Do I fucking wait?
Like, why did I...
Use it to learn the crackers recipe?
Did I not learn the crackers recipe?
What the fuck?
Oh my god, keep forgetting to read.
I keep forgetting to read.
Alright, I learned the crackers recipe, Mickey.
I did it.
I finally learned to read.
Great, now we need to water them before they dry out.
Minnie always says to pay attention to the leaves on the plant.
They'll let you know when it's time to water.
I'm glad you found the royal watering can.
That'll be real helpful when you're gardening.
Give it a try, Jeff Bezos.
Oh gosh.
I just... I just watered it.
Did I...
What the fuck?
Oh, okay, I did it.
Alright, harvest.
Harvest, harvest, harvest, harvest, harvest.
Mickey, I got the...
Goofy!
Where did he come from?
How did you get here?
How the fuck did you get here?
Where did you come from?
Hi there, pal.
Gosh, it's somebody new.
Say, you're not the scary kind of stranger, are you?
You're just a friend.
I haven't met yet, right?
Of course I'm a...
I guess I can be a little scared.
Of course I'm your friend, Goofy.
That's reassuring.
It's been a real long time since I've seen everybody else.
Gosh.
Oh gosh.
I've been waiting for somebody to come along ever since the sky got dark and the night thorns crept in.
But now you're here.
Yuck.
We're gonna be good pals.
I just know it.
If that ain't too foreign...
Yuck.
Gee, there's so much I wanna show ya.
There's my stall.
We'll have to clean...
No!
He's sad!
But where's Donald?
Cause I, of course, I had to find my lucky fishing rod.
Slow down, Goofy.
I think I already found your fishing rod.
Only one problem.
It seems to be broken.
Minus one.
Thanks!
Oh gosh!
Thanks, Jeff Bezos!
Let me see.
Oh, it was just jammed up with seaweed.
But it's all fixed now.
Tell ya what.
Now that I have my lucky fishing rod back, I'll give you this one I found after forgetting so we can fish together.
I think it belonged to our old ruler.
Hey, look!
It seems to like you.
Wait, am I the old ruler that just happens to forgot?
Because I'm so magical.
That must be it.
You do seem pretty magical.
Well, here you go.
It's all yours.
This.
I got my magic wand.
My magic fishing rod.
King Bezos.
And here's a goofy hat so you can look like a real angler.
Oh my god, I got a fishing hat.
What do you think of that hat?
Pretty spiffy, huh?
It's a bit...
goofy.
Oh, yeah.
That's what's so great about it.
Alrighty, let me show you how to use your new fishing rod.
Oh, nice.
My magic fishing rod!
And thus I learn...
And thus the world learn how to fish.
Hold to cast your line.
Okay.
That seems easy.
Alright, I need to learn...
Sorry Merlin, I'm gonna go fish.
It's time.
It's time to fish.
This is it.
Watch me fish.
Alright, hold to cast your line.
Press left click button quickly every time the circle turns green.
Okay, that's easy.
Phew.
Oh.
Oh!
This is easy.
Okay, this is easy.
Goofy is watching me fish.
Oh.
Yeah!
Goofy!
God, I'm a natural.
Bezos the cat.
Oh, what do you know?
You're a natural.
What do I do with this?
Gosh, lots of things.
You can cook it for a meal.
Or you can sell your fish at my stall.
As soon as we get it reopened, that is.
Yay!
I did it!
Alright, how do we fix your stall?
Gosh, I guess it's a little more run down than I thought.
But that's okay.
Under Scrooge's construction company can fix it right up.
Use the sign to call him.
Oh shit!
Scrooge!
It's about time Goofy fixed this place up.
I'm glad he's got you to help.
Now let's get down to business.
Goofy can have this stall at no extra cost.
Since the family needs it.
But next time, I won't be generous.
What say ya?
What say ye?
Alright, let's fix the stall.
Goofy's stall is now open for business!
That was fast.
If you see another property you're interested in...
Don't hesitate to let me know!
Simply go to the sign next to it.
Oh shit!
That's fast.
Who does this?
Is it just Scrooge?
Oh, it's... I can buy like cabbages and seeds.
Be active in the valley, gather... sell what you don't need and receive coins.
Alright, cool.
Is that it?
I can upgrade it?
Goofy could buy and sell more products so you can make more improvements?
No.
But this is a sound investment!
Well come back here when...
No, what the fuck?
Why would I need...
Wait, I need to talk to you.
Scrooge, get back here!
Scrooge!
I need...
You have a mission!
I need to talk to you!
Well done, Jeff Bezos.
With Goofy back in business, you can make more money!
Then, when you're ready to invest in my grand reopening...
Come find myself!
I have to invest in your store?
Are you ready to invest?
There will be all sorts of furniture and clothing to purchase.
And trust me or my name...
A THOUSAND QUART!
Yeah, no.
Do I even have a thousand quart?
I'm gonna talk to fucking Merlin.
Fuck that shit.
Hello!
Bravo!
Well done, Jeff Bezos!
Not only have you driven back the darkness that was hanging over the village...
But...
You found all the tools that were left by our previous ruler!
With their enchantments, you're well armed to face what lies ahead.
The pickaxe can only be wielded by one who is worthy.
Which you most certainly are.
In your hands, it will split rocks with just a swing.
The watering can never needs to be refilled.
It will speed up the growing process for crops.
And keep all the blooms here healthy.
The fishing rod needs no bait.
And never...
Oh my god!
That's why they're all magical!
As for the shovel...
Well, it's just a shovel.
What?
I literally destroyed the moon!
It is not just a shovel, Merlin!
I destroyed the moon!
But a very good one.
You'll need it for guarding and finding objects hidden in the ground around the valley.
Now that you've found all the royal tools...
The wishing well is sensing your newfound powers.
Be ready to take on the well's duty and collect the dreamlight needed to remove the nightthorns from the castle door.
Let's start with how it all works.
Gaze into the well to see what the valley needs.
Completing even the simplest tasks will bring great change and help end the forgetting.
As long as they're done in a spirit of love, care, and friendship.
Then, once you get enough dreamlight to remove those pesky nightthorns from the castle...
Come and find me!
Yay!
I'm level two!
Jesus Christ, this is a very grindy game.
I've noticed.
Oh my god, this game is actually...
Oh, stop!
I don't want to keep petting you, Capybara!
I'm trying to check the dream!
Alright, foraging.
I got this.
How many fucking...
Dream things do I need, anyway?
Who are some of the villagers here?
Oh, there's Mirabelle.
I like how there's only Mirabelle.
Wait, what's this game's last update?
Where's Donald Duck?
I want Donald in my...
I don't care about Minnie.
What the fuck is wrong?
There's something wrong with Maui's model.
There's something.
New 2000?
That's a lot of dreamlight.
Why is mother...
What about Rapunzel?
What about...
Why are the lions here?
I like how the lions are here, too.
Tim Burton's, Wally, Mike Wachowski.
Yeah, it was in Wreck-It Ralph.
I like how it's... Vanellope's there, when the move...
When Ralph himself is not there.
Uh...
Alright.
Let's see.
What even are the rest of my missions?
Use the water...
I have to do it again?
Oh no, I glitched it.
Oh no.
I... I...
I watered the plants before they were supposed to be...
Oh no!
Mickey's quest.
I... I sequence broke the Mickey quest.
I actually sequence broke it.
I can't believe it!
I actually sequence broke it!
Oh no!
Alright.
I think this is a good time to call it today.
The adventures of Jeff Bezos will have to stop here.
But before we do...
Let's take a picture.
Wait.
No.
Change.
Move camera.
Hello?
Jeff Bezos!
I wanna...
Okay.
Wait.
Alright, Mickey.
I want to take a picture with you, Mickey.
This time.
Mickey, why did you walk away?
Mickey, why...
Mickey, stop!
Stop, Mickey!
Okay.
What if like...
Here.
I need you to...
There we go.
Oh.
Nope.
There we go.
Me and my friend Mickey!
Let's go!
Oh!
Okay.
Yeah.
Wait.
Let's see.
This.
Yeah.
And then...
What...
What expression?
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh, I have to like...
Okay.
This night Disney at Dreamlight Valley.
There we go.
Alright.
Okay.
Uh...
Capture.
Hide.
Alright, guys.
Wait.
Me and the best...
Alright.
That seems like a good time to call it today.
We're gonna go to the next one.
We're in the Coopee...
Coopee.
Coopee!
Hey, everybody!
I was a wild start of the day!
I'm gonna take my...
I'm gonna...
Um...
I'm gonna push the stream.
God of War stream back.
Ma...
I'll let you guys know if I'm gonna push the God of War stream back.
Maybe an hour.
Because I'm gonna head straight to the PC store now.
But!
But I had a great time everybody!
As always everyone, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everybody!
Bye guys!
Bye!